how old were each of you when you
started you were 12 12 and I was 10.
have you ever wondered what it would be
like to grow up on a film set we've
compiled a list of actors who've done
just that and have also continued to do
so for decades let's get into it I think
I always liked making movies when I was
younger like it was always really fun to
me number one starting out at just nine
Millie Bobby Brown really did grow up on
set she started Landing small commercial
roles before transitioning into TV shows
like Once Upon a Time in Wonderland in
2013. of course we all know her as 11 in
Netflix's stranger things which she
landed when she was just 12 years old
but did you know she almost didn't
audition for it she had a discouraging
moment with a producer who told her she
was too mature to be a child actor my
parents told me just do this one last
audition on tape and then you can go
outside and play with your friends again
that audition landed her the role of 11.
now she's even started producing and
showing interest in directing clearly
that producer couldn't have been more
wrong
number two everyone's favorite Hermione
Granger Emma Watson was so ambitious at
only nine years old portraying the role
of Hermione what's fascinating about her
transition into other roles like in The
Perks of Being a Wallflower was that she
was a little unsure of herself I didn't
really know if I believed in myself yet
as an actress outside of the role of
Hermione she didn't even know if she was
capable of playing other characters so I
just sort of like needed someone to sort
of come along and be like no you can do
this number three Christina Ricci giving
us Decades of entertainment at the young
age of nine years old Christina landed
her first role in the movie mermaids
which was followed by her Infamous role
as Wednesday Adams in The Addams Family
if the first thing you experience is
that level of Fame how do you ever match
that Rush ever again it even comes full
circle with her starring in the upcoming
Netflix show Wednesday alongside Jenna
Ortega number four one Apollo
Hollywood's most beloved performers
emmy-winning actor Zendaya got her start
at the age of 14 on the Disney Channel
series shake it up she was in shows like
blackish and Casey Undercover but what
really brought her name out into the
world was the HBO series Euphoria where
she plays the complex and deeply
troubled Rue Bennett
are you high
ER asked about her graceful trajectory
from Child stardom in comparison to
other child actors it's important not to
judge any other person's career or
trajectory because when you're a young
actor you are growing up in front of the
world sometimes that's not easy
everybody has their own path number five
who knew lying about your age could work
out so well Mila Kunis landed a breakout
role as Jackie on That 70s Show at the
age of 14. 70 show changed my life
forever though at the time of the
audition she told the casting directors
that she was 18. this ended up being a
breakout rule for her and she continued
starring in major movies and films to
this day the funny thing about this
though is she didn't even want to work
on That 70s Show she wanted a role in a
soap opera so she could work with a guy
she thought was really hot I was like I
don't really care about this weird show
about the 70s I don't understand it but
this this show is great right number six
he is a wizard there's not a single
person we can think of who doesn't think
of Harry Potter when hearing the name
Daniel Radcliffe he landed this
incredible breakout role at just 12
years old and continued to portray the
role of Harry until he was about 22.
that's 10 years of his life on one set I
got a taste for that young and so I
think that made all the other weird
stuff about life more than worth it
number seven who else is just grateful
for Winona Ryder's on-screen existence
after her first role in the movie Lucas
at age 14 she landed the role in Tim
Burton's Beetlejuice when she was 17.
that would be the start of her majorly
successful decades-long career though
she garnered major success she had
difficulties being in the spotlight at
such a young age it is difficult to be
judged to be reviewed as a teenager
things seem to come full circle for her
as well with her starring role in
stranger things alongside an ensemble of
child actors number eight the troubled
teen ashtray his fate was sealed in
euphoria's season 2 finale Euphoria was
javon's first TV gig and he continues to
lay the road map for his acting career
being new to acting he tries to learn as
much as he can from his more seasoned
co-stars I think what I learned from
Zendaya was like how prepared and how
focused she was on set number nine
nominated for an Academy Award at the
young age of 10. Little Miss Sunshine
was just the first of many movies
Abigail Breslin would star in she didn't
really find her love for acting until
filming My Sister's Keeper in 2009. the
director Nick cassavetes pushed her in a
direction that helped her find a
different kind of love for playing
characters he really gave me a lot of
trust with the character and talked to
me a lot more like I was an adult number
10. and another wizard cast as Ron
Weasley in Harry Potter at the age of 12
like his co-stars that's where he spent
his childhood did you know though he
actually contemplated walking away from
the Harry Potter series I definitely
remember thinking during one extended
break this whole thing is so
all-consuming do I really want to go
back maybe it's just not for me after
thinking about it years later he thinks
it might have just been his
all-consuming Teen Angst coming out
number 11.
Umbrella Academy wasn't his start before
the Umbrella Academy Aidan Gallagher
starred in Nicky Ricky Dicky and Dawn on
Nickelodeon at 11 years old it was tough
for the series creator of Umbrella
Academy to find the right child actor to
play five they auditioned hundreds of
kids before Aiden walked in the room he
sat down and said he would kill for this
role he knew everything about the
graphic novel and was very insightful
when he read the sides I was blown away
his talent was recognized right away you
need a certain gravitas to play a 58
year old man trapped inside a 13 year
old's body Aiden had that and then some
number 12. a fan favorite from the HBO
series Game of Thrones she landed the
role of Arya Stark at the age of 13 and
played it from the years 2011 to 2019.
After Game of Thrones came to an end she
continued to further her career by
Landing huge roles in films like the New
Mutants with many more projects to come
we definitely haven't seen the end of
Maisie Williams's on-screen career when
did Maisie Williams become famous
shortly after starting acting number 13
13 Reasons Why anyone before starring in
this breakout Netflix series Dylan
Minnette was cast in one of the most
popular shows of all time at the young
age of only nine years old he was cast
to play the child version of the
infamous Michael Scofield in the show
Prison Break believe it or not he
actually got signed at six years old
because his mom heard an ad on the radio
about a convention looking for models
and actors and they decided to check it
out I just went up and I asked if I
could sing a song and so I saying bye
bye bye by NSync number 14. Mayim
bialik's first acting job was in
Pumpkinhead when she was only 12. she
continued working on a number of
projects until Landing the role of
Blossom in the sitcom of the same name
that propelled her career you're taking
yourself out of your situation
forgetting what you're doing at the time
and you're becoming another person
number 15 she didn't just start with
Modern Family starting out at just age
four Sarah Hyland did commercials and
voice-overs before landing her first big
role in the 1997 film private parts
she's continued acting ever since even
through her father's dismay the actress
said my dad is an actor so they know how
tough the entertainment industry can be
I gave myself two months to book a job
one month later I was cast on Modern
Family
growing up on set couldn't have been
easy but it seems like these Stars
didn't really know an alternative who's
your favorite actor on the list